hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar no sweat nano particle
characterization with stunner i am
kayleigh bach of labyrinths and i'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots and brought to you by
unchained labs
to learn more please visit
unchainedlabs.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd now like to welcome our speaker
nellis dennis product manager at
unchained labs nellis you may now begin
your presentation
thank you for that introduction welcome
to this webinar no sweat nanoparticle
characterization on stunner
meet stutter an instrument with a unique
combination of uv-vis and dls stutter
has a variety of applications for
proteins and nucleic acids for aav and
also for the topic for today
nanoparticles
i'm sure everyone knows the famous
phrase life is like a box of chocolates
you never know what you're gonna get
from the movie forrest gump and he's
right without biting them open there's
really not a way to know what is inside
nanoparticles are very similar once made
you know what you want to be in there
but it's difficult to know if it's
actually present and what its
concentration is without breaking them
down
there are a lot of properties that are
important during development of
nanoparticles what particle shape you
want and what size this should have
which lipids or other components will be
used and in which ratios
choosing your api payload choosing
potential surfactants what charge the
particle particle should have in which
buffer and which ph it should be in
now once the particle is made two
important questions come up as well
what is my particle's payload
concentration
and does it have the size i want it to
have
nanoparticle size is critical to the
performance of a successful drug so when
you've got lots of buffers formulations
and rna constructs to test you want to
be gathering size data on everything
nanoparticles are booming and they come
in a lot of different forms liposomes
lipid nanoparticles solid lipid
nanoparticles lipid nano emulsions
polymeric nano carriers and many many
more particles with their own unique
tweak and proprietary content for many
different applications
in gene therapy for example but also
cancer treatment vaccine development and
other biopharma
one of the reasons for this abundance of
options is the fact that a variety of
payloads can be encapsulated of course
making nanomedicine an option in a lot
of areas the payload can be rna dna
protein or practically any other active
pharmaceutical ingredient and then there
is a range of opium options for each
category for example for rna it can be
different types for example like
messenger rna but also small interfering
rna
stunner tackles these two questions
simultaneously without nanoparticle
applications stutter delivers low volume
high trooper dls without the need for
dilutions to get the size and pdi data
you need on the same two microliter
sample standard quantifies your total
payload concentration whether it's rna
dna protein or another api without the
need for any reagent standard or
fluorescent dyes
all this is done in a 96-well
plate-based format that powers
high-throughput analysis of nanoparticle
samples fresh out of mixing
now stunner contains two technologies to
read each sample you have this for
concentration and dls for sizing so
simply add in 2 microliter of your
nanoparticle sample into the input well
and it will be pulled into the
microfluidic reservoir
at this step the sample can sit for up
to two hours before reading with no
evaporation now after the plate is
loaded into the instrument the circuit
is red first when it's empty and that
will remove any absorbance contribution
from the plastic
and then a pump applies a small vacuum
which moves the sample into the micro
cuvettes to be read
because the circuit has fixed path
lengths it can make very precise and
accurate measurements
here we can see exactly what sample
loading looks like with the help of some
fluorescein and a black light in two
wells we've already added two microliter
fluorescein
as you can see to load another sample
you simply add in that 2 microliter into
the input well and the sample wicks into
the plate
on the left you can see those loaded
samples
and on the right you can see the samples
after being measured with stunner the
two diamond shapes are the cuvettes for
one sample what this also shows is after
pumping all the sample remains in your
consumable and so there's no contact
between the samples and the actual
pumping system no contamination possible
lnp size is critical for the performance
of a successful drug throw a stick in
the literature and you'll hit a paper
with lnp size data often showing the
link between size and the effective dose
needed
here we're looking at intensity
distribution data for a whole plate of
lmps with the average diameter noted as
the value below each distribution
these mrna lnps had a hydrodynamic
diameter of 79 nanometers plus or minus
one percent and a pdi of 0.14 plus or
minus 0.02
standard will provide dls results just
how you like it with hydrodynamic
diameter and pdi but now you no longer
have to be limited by dls data that has
to be manually gathered for about a
dozen pieces of data in a day
now dls can keep up with lmp samples as
fast as you can make them allowing you
to run as many replicas as you want
stutters dls gives you the high triplet
power to gather the size and size
distribution data on 96 samples in less
than an hour
with just 10 minutes of hands-on time
stunner will do all the rest in about 45
minutes
while other instruments will be one by
one resulting in more than three hours
hands-on time to get the ls on those
same 96 samples
now let's focus in on the quant part how
to use standard to get the payload
concentration of your nanoparticle
the most famous product with
nanoparticles are for sure the latest
mrna vaccines an important factor is of
course the dose
dye based quantification are multi-step
required illusions use costly standards
and dies requires hours of analysis and
hands-on lab work and includes breaking
down the precious particle you just made
there needs to be a better way
and you could try to quantity of events
but nanoparticle solutions have tons of
durability so traditional uvs approaches
fail
until stutter
load up an lmp sample into a stunner
sample well and you'll quickly see it
being wicked into the serpentine
reservoir and held there to read the
plate stunner will pump the sample into
the 0.1 and 0.7 millimeter pad length
micro cuvettes for uv absorbance
measurements
when reading lmps the combination of
standards two fixed path-length
microcuvets provides precision and a
broad dynamic range
since lnps are typically very turbid
cloudy samples the short paddlings are
needed so that light can pass through
and enable absorbance measurements
now let's take a look at some rna lnp
samples the empty lnps create a whole
lot of signal that looks like absorbance
but it's actually turbidity and it
usually isn't helpful and just gets in
the way
because all that turbidity makes
quantifying with traditional uv is
almost impossible the total arnae quant
by uv is normally a big challenge
for example if we squint at the full
curve we can see the rna bump at about
260 nanometers but the difference is
pretty small to analyze this we have to
separate out the signal from the
turbidity from the signal from the
actual lnp absorbance due to rna and
other lnp components
on the left we have the raw data again
for our full lnps and on the right
standard has used our unmixed algorithms
to isolate the impact of turbidity and
remove it this is shown by the black
line indicating the total signal and the
gray line indicates the contribution
from turbidity the remainder is green
and blue green is the isolated signal
from rna and that will be our total rna
concentration
blue is the uv is absorbent signal from
other components in our sample uv
absorbing lipids excipients and buffer
components stutter separates the
contribution of those three groups
turbidity rna and other components to
quantify the total rna concentration
this in less than a minute per sample
from just two microliter without any
dice reagents or complicated workflow
stenos rna concentrations agree closely
with the total mrna concentration
determined by rubygreen the twofold
dilution series of firefly luciferase
mrna lnps
showed highly linear results down to 1.2
microgram per milliliter
error bars are plus or minus 1 standard
deviation
as mentioned stunner lets you run 96
samples in an hour here we can see 96
replicates of rna lnps where the green
is the rna concentration
and it's also mentioned below the graphs
and the gray is the turbidity signal the
question of variation is a spectacular
1.54 over these 96 complicated samples
so quan exactly like you won using
ribbon green to quantify your rna means
you'll need to lyse your particles use
two standard curves with costly
standards basically to measure four
samples you'll end up measuring 96
samples including all the standards and
controls
while doing four samples on standard is
simple die and standard free no lice is
needed you'll get rna concentration and
size in about 4 minutes for those 4
samples
rna lmps are of course not the only
nanoparticles out there as mentioned in
the very start of this presentation
nanomedicines have a broad area of
applications so let's take a look at
some other potential payloads
these next graphs show results from
stunner on either dna lnps or protein
lmps studder applies those same
algorithms to remove the turbidity
signal so you can get an accurate dna or
protein concentration without dyes or
breaking down your particle
and it doesn't stop there labs are
making all kinds of nanoparticles so
starter allows you to customize its
algorithms to look at the spectra
simply tell stunner what to look for and
the software will do the rest
this is a combination of a protein and
rna in a nanoparticle stunner will unmix
the turbidity signal and the protein and
rna signal
to allow
you to quantify whatever you want here
you can easily get the protein
concentration but if you want to
flip-flop and quantify rna payload
instead that is no problem with a click
of a button you'll get those results as
well
and as mentioned a couple of times
nanomedicine is hot and new unique and
proprietary particles with their custom
payload are developed rapidly
teach stunner all about the uf is
absorbance of your nanoparticle
shown here is a setup in the software
and the results where stunner allows you
to create your own reference spectra
providing the possibility to set up your
custom application and quantify exactly
what you're interested in
and this is how it works for your unique
particle you've shown standard what your
pure api is and it will deconvolute it
from the raw spectrum to get you the
result you need
skip the disruption step and quantify
any payload whether that's rna dna a
protein or whatever small molecule
standard makes quantification crazy
simple to free you from complicated
workflows costly dyes and wasteful
standard curves
we also have ikeoq procedures available
and standard software is 21cfr part 11
compliant with full audit rail and
electronic signature capabilities
and for labs doing manufacturing quality
assurance and quality control stunner
has a performance verification
these tests meet the united states
pharmacopoeia and the european
pharmacopoeia guidelines for uvs
spectrometers the tests and all
necessary calculations are handled
automatically by the software
stunner's nanoparticle applications
combine both uvs and dls technologies on
a single sample to deliver total payload
quantification and low volume size and
pdi results
so that is how standard delivers
label-free standard free and hassle-free
gene therapy quantification
so always know exactly what you got in
your chocolates without the need to bite
in them first
thank you for your attention i'm happy
to take any questions now
thank you nellis for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for
all right let's get started our first
question asks i have a hybrid particle
containing protein and dna will that
work
uh yes no that will work so with within
latest changes you can um teach stunner
what the absorbance of your
um
specific dna particle is and your
protein particle and standard will
deconvolute those of course you can also
use
preset dna and preset protein spectra to
do so so it will not be a problem and
you'll get quantification like you want
great thank you
our next question here asks
is it compatible with samples in ethanol
uh yeah so um you know normally fresh
out of mixing um nanoparticles can
contain a high amount of ethanol
up to 20 ethanol will not be an issue
above that
you'll need a little bit of buffer
exchange first
if you you're looking into
for example automated buffer exchange we
also have a system for that big tuna
but otherwise everything below 20
ethanol should be an issue
great thank you
all right another question here asks can
this system be automated
um yes one of the great features about
stenner is or or plate is sbs compatible
and so it can be pipetted with any
liquid handler or a multi-channel pipet
or anything like that um and we have a
specific api
setup
and so with any driver liquid handler
anything can be integrated so you can
have a fully automated setup
with
stutter wonderful
all right another question here asks
is a standard curve of some sort needed
or blinking with an empty nanoparticle
um so no that's one of the great things
you don't you don't need any standard
curve or anything like that you don't
need to blank with your empty
nanoparticle
if you have normal
well the default nanoparticles like we
use the lmps you can just use the app as
is if you have absorbing nanoparticles
you'll need to teach stunner a little
bit but then you don't need to blank or
use a standard curve at all afterwards
so
it's very easy and straightforward to
use
great and i want to thank our audience
for these wonderful questions coming in
we have a few more here
another one asks how about quantifying
the payload of viral particles like aavs
and lentiviral vectors
so for uh viral particles um more
specifically for aav we have a specific
application for that um so it's it works
a bit the same way so we can deconvolute
the protein and the single-stranded dna
and actually with that application we
can give you
a full capsid tiger a total capsid titer
and empty full ratio and you can see
aggregation information as well so
for aav that's very specific on other
viral vectors
you can still do that same deconvolution
but we don't have a specific application
for that
but of course
it's worth testing out
great and it looks like we have time for
one more question here and this last one
asked or mentioned that you have not
touched on latex or magnetic mp what can
the stunner do to analyze these types of
samples
so we
don't have much experience with specific
latex or magnetic nanoparticles um but
as long as these
absorb um
it will definitely be possible or at
least that your payload absorbs um
and i wouldn't suspect any issues um
and so it could need some tweaking for
for
the actual if there's empty nanoparticle
absorbance we would need to adjust for
that a bit but after that it should be
fine i would think um yeah if you have
those specific samples
we can always do a demo or anything like
that so
well thank you again nellis for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor unchained labs for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
elaborates will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone goodbye